Hey, was ist los, 3castle Oxenberg, du hast
bereits ein paar Alben veröffentlicht, also
wollte ich wissen, ob du irgendwelche
Lieblingsalben oder Lieblingssongs hast oder ob du
einen anderen Song hast, bei dem dein Ding wow
, das ist das Schlimmste, was wir je gemacht haben,
und mein Zweites  Die Frage ist, gibt es
Städte oder Länder, in denen es dir mehr Spaß macht
, dort Konzerte zu geben als in anderen
Ländern oder Städten? Nun, ich hoffe, du
beantwortest meine Fragen mit deinem Rock.
Ja, wir haben, wir haben
Fans in Luxemburg, ja, es gab
Zeiten, in denen wir Dinge aufgenommen haben, von
denen ich dachte, dass das überhaupt nicht sehr
gut ist, und um ganz
ehrlich und sehr genau zu sein, gab
es tatsächlich ein Video, als wir das Video für
Rockstar gemacht haben, als ich es gesehen habe  Beim ersten Rohschnitt
dachte ich, es sei der schlimmste Mist, den
ich je in meinem Leben gesehen habe. Ich finde, das
ist schrecklich. Ich kann nicht glauben, dass wir dafür tatsächlich
bezahlt haben  es war nicht
so  Schlecht, dann der nächste Schnitt im nächsten Schnitt
und dann weißt du, am Ende finde
ich es eigentlich ziemlich gut,
aber ich hatte keine Ahnung, dass es
von diesem ersten Rohentwurf, der
einfach schrecklich war, in das Video übergehen würde
Jeder konnte es auf all seinen Videostationen sehen
, und was Städte betrifft, in denen wir
mehr spielen als in anderen Städten, gibt
es nicht wirklich Städte, in denen wir mehr spielen
als in anderen Städten. Es gibt Tage, an denen
wir mehr spielen als an anderen Tagen,
denn wenn Sie  donnerstag, freitag und samstag spielen darf,
niemand sich Sorgen macht,
am nächsten tag aufzustehen und zur arbeit zu gehen, niemand sich
Sorgen um dich macht, du kennst den babysitter
und die kinder oder was auch immer es sein mag, oder
du weißt, ob jemand am
nächsten tag montag, dienstag, mittwoch, wenn wir
spiel das lange set du siehst ein paar
leute gehen ich muss morgen arbeiten
komm leute geh zu meinem lieblingslied also
da ist ein bisschen davon was passiert
also ist es nicht so sehr von welcher stadt oder welchem
s abhängen kann o  An w
n, wenn ich s
hr überzeugend bin und die Menge überreden kann,
Sie wissen, dass ich m
ch am nächsten Tag krank zur Arbeit oder zur Schule melde, dann habe ich meine Arbei
erledigt und es wird ein wunderbarer Abend
also los geht'
Ich hoffe, das hat dir ein paar deiner Fragen beantwortet